okay hi everyone nice to be doing a lot
of live streaming today um
we have another discussion here about
sort of an exploratory discussion about
molecular computing
and
[Music]
here's the question
if you're going to do
information processing
with molecules
what's the right way to do that
and
the
one answer to that is
you know in other words so in a sense
uh you know what is the data structure
um
that
in which you store information so for a
very basic question if we're doing you
know information processing or
computation with molecules
um
you know
how
you know what's the data structure
um
to store
information and that may not even really
necessarily mean anything because
um
uh
the it could be
that
the journey is the story so to speak
that is that the process of getting to
an output the process of of chemical you
know the sequence of chemical reactions
could actually be the thing that
represents
what is going on in the computation so
one possibility is you make a particular
molecule
another possibility is you have a
certain distribution
of molecular concentrations
the more exotic case would be
uh
there is
a
um
[Music]
a kind of a multi-way graph
of
um
different uh
possible transformations yeah
yeah yeah yeah um
and and um
sorry i'm just trying to organize
something here
um
just one second
[Music]
um
anyway so so uh right so my question
would be
in traditional chemistry
or
things i mean
you know when you think of chemistry
as information processing
are there any other
sort of places i mean like
you know you have a signaling pathway
for example
um
that's essentially
that's the most common case where you're
sort of representing
is that the right thing is that the
right way to think about it or is that
not the right way to think about it
um
that's certainly one way to think about
it i mean
in biology signaling networks are very
important for
passing information for example from
outside the cell to inside the cell from
the cytoplasm to the nucleus
and things like that
yeah but if we if we look at what's
going on in a cell okay so that the you
know how do we characterize
you know quotes what's going on in a
cell
and and the answer tends to be
we've got things like transcription
starts up for some particular
uh protein and things like this
and that's i mean
that's and you make a particular
molecule that's one type of thing that
can happen
right and and in the cell the way that
this data is typically characterized
these days it's basically by
how much protein expression you know how
much of the various proteins have been
expressed over time that's how those
changes yeah right
right so that's you know
it's like uh looking at
how much
now i don't know whether i mean there
are presumably other things that happen
like proteins combine
and i'm not sure how much that is part
of the characterization of what's going
on i mean clearly there are cases where
i don't know proteins will will sort of
arrange themselves to make i don't know
i don't know what like insulin i think
makes itself from you know from putting
together a cluster of of different
subunits and things i believe you're
talking about the quaternary structure
of the protein there
yes yes you know that would be that um
not for insulin but things like
hemoglobin where there are multiple
chains but
there are uh proteins often interact
within
the cell
forming conjugates that then
either become catalytic and do something
a particular way or they they
initiate a signaling event
proteins interact with receptors
both uh on the
uh within the cell of the cell cytoplasm
are the cell membrane
both intracellularly and extracellularly
to to do that so the protein
interactions
what they call the interactome
is very important for
conveying information we don't
understand a lot of it though
okay but my question is
in that interactome
the basic data structure
ends up being you've got all these
different possible proteins
that can get expressed or not expressed
or whatever else genes that can get
expressed and not expressed
and
you're essentially if you say what is
the current state of the cell
you would be able to characterize i mean
okay the the the state of the cell must
depend on
you know
concentrations of things and also some
spatial information
i mean it doesn't usually one doesn't
usually like is this thing sitting in
the you know in the golgi apparatus or
something like this
right or pores on the cell surface i
mean you you just say i mean usually
it's just the concentration it's just it
has this number of
of um
this kind of you know
uh whatever they are
cd8 things on a t cell or whatever else
it is right yeah correct it's really
mostly concentrations as far as we know
right now it's mostly not spatial
information right and that generally has
to do with the way it's measured they
with green fluorescent dyes tagging and
things like that you can and
microscopy you can start
localizing
uh where they are
but i don't know if anybody has
quantitative ways of of measuring that
over time
well i remember
then you need a coordinate frame as well
right i remember millions of years ago
people talking about you know detailed
morphology of the spatial information in
microtubules for example
you know spatial cellular automata
running
uh you know cas running in um
uh in microtubules those kinds of things
and i mean people
talk about you know again for nerve
cells there's the whole question of you
know does it matter
you know is there a lot of detailed
processing in the in the whole dendritic
uh
you know in the set of dendritic in the
dendritic tree or is it just
this overall excitation or or what but i
think
the the question really so what what
we're saying is in traditional chemistry
it's mostly a story of chemical
concentrations and it's mostly one is
imagining mostly and in some sense
it's like everything is fluid there's
not a solid
you know the only thing with the spatial
information
is on the genome where
it is essentially string matching that
is determining you know so the the
spatial information
um you know that this
uh
there's there's sort of coordinates by
string matching
which is the genome case
well by string matching which is either
genome
or
you know docking into active sites and
things like this if i'm not mistaken
yeah but even then docking into active
sites depends on where the receptor uh
or the the enzyme are located
bob doesn't chemical potential come into
play here
besides concentration
which i guess you could say that but
um i'm not sure what you you know how
you would characterize chemical
potential in an enzyme reaction
i thought chemical potential so
um
it uh
um
well okay so remind me chemical
potential in the usual boltzmann
distribution you have e to the minus
beta h by beta e
plus mu times the number density is that
right
isn't that a concentration isn't that
just a way of representing concentration
in the canonical ensemble
my step max a bit rusty uh we always i
always thought about it in the uh
courses that i taught that it was uh
gibbs energy divided by the change in
the number of particles and the amount
of moles
and then of course you can take that and
divide it by the volume and get a mol
i think it's equivalent to
concentrations i mean am i very confused
yeah but when you start talking about
concentration at the molecular or atomic
scale rather than
uh in bulk i think yeah it's i think
it's a different game no no but the
point is this it's just like temperature
right temperature at the microscopic
level you know the boltzmann
distribution is what links macroscopic
temperature with microscopic information
i'm pretty sure chemical potential is
what links
macroscopic number density or
macroscopic concentration with
microscopic you know it's asking what's
the probability that you have that
you're occupying this microscopic state
oh it's an exponential distribution that
depends on the energy it depends on the
chemical potential etc it depends on
temperature and chemical potential
temperatures the thing conjugate to
energy chemical potential i think is the
thing constant to conjugate to number
density if i'm not mistaken
okay but so so
this is that but there's also
potentially
i don't know whether there are other
kinds of coordinates used in in in
biology there are other ways of getting
coordinates so to speak don't know
um
i mean i i feel like
in
clearly
well yes i mean okay another another
form is eg in dendritic
in in um
uh not branchial trees but bronchial
trees
um you know or dendritic spines or
whatever else there is some
um
what are they called dendritic what the
heck are they called on on a neuron what
are those called dendritic the uh the
dendrites um receive the signal and and
the actions i know that's another yeah
what's the thing dendritic trees i guess
they're called okay yeah that's a weird
name because i'm realizing that
dendritic means like a tree like from
dendros and greek and so trees is like
saying it's like saying saying it twice
so to speak tree like tree yes
but anyway so i mean those are cases
where there is some spatial information
that
is might be being used other than this
kind of molecular scale
sort of string matching type information
but okay
the big question as far as i'm concerned
is
if we are going to you know we're going
to represent information we're going to
represent computations chemically
what's the right way to do that
in other words biology has chosen a
particular way of doing it in which it's
very big on string matching et cetera et
cetera
and
um
i'm just curious
if
we
so question for bob that i i think i've
asked bob over
at least 25 years right it's like if
you're gonna do computation molecules
what's the right basis collection of
molecules to use
you know what kinds of molecules because
clearly
you know clearly one kind of molecules
okay the success story is biola is
biology
yeah
which is you know dna plus proteins
for a very large part yeah
but so the question is could one imagine
any other class of molecules
that
maybe don't use as much string matching
stuff but maybe use another
form of because string matching is one
way
to determine what happens in a chemical
reaction it's a very
it's a very combinatorial way to
determine what chemical reactions are
possible but one can imagine much
coarser ways to determine what chemical
reactions are possible
that makes sense
and
well the only thing that comes to mind
for collections of molecules to use as
your basis set as it were
are some of the things that have been
done since the the late 1990s in terms
of combinatorial synthesis
uh or modular synthesis where you have
uh a particular type of reaction instead
of amide bond forming the way you do in
proteins you
form other types of bombs but in a very
modular repetitive way
and then you have very large collections
of
reactants that fit in the different
slots in that process
and then you can generate you know from
a small number of reactions very large
number of compounds uh for you know drug
discovery for example that's that's
where it has come up
uh
but it's a very
other than other than the biologics that
are made of proteins and things what
other sort of i don't know hetero
polymer like things are there that have
been done for drugs
uh just these combinatorial libraries
are not really polymeric uh there are
you know a small number of repeating
units you know
two three four maybe five
where they do all kinds of combinations
in those positions
uh and what are they typically what are
what are they chemically
uh
they're
various kinds of uh things you can
couple easily uh some of them are amid
formations i don't remember all of them
for sure but um
very relatively simple chemistry that
you can get a robot to carry out
uh in a very repetitive uh high-yield
way
so this is this is for combinatorial
chemistry and what what is the typical
i mean the you know you're generating
millions of compounds or more
i
you could
on the order of of millions potentially
yeah
you might you might have 30 or 50 types
of amines and
a couple of dozen types of acids and
you're combining them together and then
there's something else at the next
location you know so you multiply that
result by 20 or 30 or 50 or 60 or
something like that and that tells you
that you know
but so so the goal here in all cases is
it fair to say
that
you know
one's using the shapes of molecules as
the i mean the ultimate thing you care
about
is is that a fair statement or is it how
much is how much is shape and charge
distribution what you care about and how
much is it actual atomic
constitution of the of the molecules for
drug discovery it's definitely shape and
charge distribution
and how much of that is you know you can
govern that to a degree by what by the
constitution by
by what building blocks you use but
ultimately
there are some interactions among those
building blocks uh that affect the the
overall shape and charge distribution
and then when they those compounds get
to the receptor there's always the
induced fit
uh effect as well
on top of that but so some i mean one
might expect that sometimes
the drug is a cage that has some weird
heavy you know heavy ion in it or
something or is that never happen i
haven't seen that i mean people have
made those they've put you know
potassium eyes inside of buckyballs and
things like that
right um
well
some some drugs do actually work that
way by sequestering
uh metal ions uh and and become uh
antibiotics and things like that
uh under these sulfur antibiotics
sulfur-based antibiotics am i
remembering the sulfur drugs no those
those don't do that i
don't recall what their mechanism is but
things like valinomycin
um is a depth of peptide it's a very
large ring structure but it folds up
very nicely
uh providing uh
something like eight coordination sites
so it can grab metals
nicely
and it uses the metals as
in its antibiotic action or not uh
i don't think it's a way of delivering
them but just a way of sequestering them
that that basically kills the the
bacteria
why does that kill the bacteria i i
don't remember okay all right never mind
that's that we're getting down in okay
but the question for us is
given that
you know
if we're asking the question how do we
so so let's imagine
that okay my goal
is to
generate and now this shows my total
lack of knowledge of chemistry you know
i want to generate like the a thing i
can see an electrophoretic gel that
makes the primes
let's say
or what's the best way okay
goal
you know generate the primes with
molecules
sample goal okay
how could we imagine doing that
what's a um like like implement let me
give an example implement the civil
veritosthenes which you say well that's
a big complicated mess but let me show
you an example i mean in um
uh let's see if i can find it
um
uh let's see
yeah here's an example
so you know let's see this is one
um
this is needless to say from the encased
book of course this is a cellular
automaton
that
implements the you know that generates
the primes
okay
so my question is how can i do that with
molecules
okay so one way you might do that is
by the molecular size it only generates
sizes that correspond to primes
okay that's an interesting idea there's
okay uh another way would be that given
one molecule you do something to it and
you know given one molecule that
represents a prime
you do something to it and it gives you
the next prime and then you do something
hopefully the same sort of thing in in a
generic way to that molecule and it
gives you the next prime in other words
you can generate them in a sequence okay
let's take the only molecular sizes of
the prime that would be very cool let's
say we could get some random
hydrocarbons and you know you do
uh you know mass spectrometry and you
find that all the all the sizes are
prime
how could we imagine generating that
so
i mean again this is state-based
information this is again
using concentration as our storage of
information
which may not be the only way to do it
and in fact may not be the richest i'm i
suspect it's not the richest way to do
it
i wasn't thinking concentration at all i
would be thinking that the molecular
structure of one prime could be used to
encode somehow
uh the starting point to get to the next
prime
well i understand that this one
generated only molecular size of the
prime so let me give you an example
there eg
you know maybe there are only
certain buckyballs that can make
certain buckyballs
so this says
so this is essentially like a tiling
problem
certainly
yeah yeah so this is
and that that way
um
and then
uh
let's see i mean
you know for a crystal we could easily
say
uh well i mean this is the thing i've
been searching for for other reasons as
is
sort of random crystal type things been
looking for those for ages
but that's a i mean let's take this
example of buckyballs right is it you
know okay so one set one thing is you
set up constraints
that only have that are only satisfied
by
by the result you want
right so i don't know what the
constraints are on buckyballs does
anybody know i mean that the um
uh you would start with c60 and then
uh
there are ways you can expand it
the structures are ellipsoidal
um or you can grow a bucky tube that has
basically a hemisphere at each end
but those tubes would definitely be a
linear sort of growth
right you could also do like cups and
moles
building where if you're building blocks
or c5 and c6 rings they don't always
seem together
close a ball but you can do the you know
half balls or half bowls or
yeah and then you could have some kind
of penrose tiling
[Music]
as
well
i'm not sure if you could do it with
carbon though but it is some aluminum
alloys do do that
okay so you're saying we could have so
so one possibility is that we have
tiling rules
that give us
certain
mathematical certain desirable i mean
that's a very difficult cad problem so
to speak design the tiling rules that
give us some output
right but that's a
that will be a possible way to do this
and then what we're asking for
is that the chemical process in its
minimum energy state
is i mean that this is like
i mean
you know this is you know this is
analogous to find the
you know
um
find the ground state of a spin glass
which we know
that can that's mappable onto the
traveling salesman problem
but that's um
uh
i mean that case is you've got a
substrate i mean
this is a case with a substrate so
remember um you know what we're talking
about there is we've got something like
an ising model where we say at every at
every node of a of a
lattice
at every you know point in a grid we
have a spin that can be up or down and
there's an energy function that
determines um the the energy based on
the
whether the spins near it are that's
aligned or anti-aligned and the question
and and as you go around that grid we're
changing whether we count the thing as
aligned or anti-line that that is
equivalent to a graph theory problem but
that requires a substrate
right so that's a case where in a sense
we are specifying our program with the
substrate
if that makes sense
yeah um
i mean and and for instance one could
imagine you know is there a substrate
and my you know is there a substrate
uh
so that
is there substrate that we can make
as a metamaterial or something
um
so that we get
uh
you know
um
so that we get eg the primes look as an
example of this okay so here's an
example
um
simpler goal
make the two more sequence
so that that sequence is
if we take a substitution system
um that sequence is one goes to one zero
uh zero goes to
am i getting this right is that the
right thing
i think that's right and i start off
with one
and i run it five steps
and
yes i think what i get here is what i
get
um
is a sequence if i say last of that
that that sequence will be will have all
kinds of
random characteristics that sequence is
not if i say for example
this line plot
of minus one to the power
that
um
uh oh wait a minute is that no it's not
periodic it can't be it's never periodic
it just wiggles between
um between those values but it's not
periodic but one could imagine
doing something
i mean again this is something where
there's a process and we could imagine
following it
but as opposed to
we've got something like this where
we're just finding the
energy
configuration by
i mean i i don't know these
right so you're saying given a set of
tiling rules there will be a certain set
of things that could come out that's one
model of of how you can compute things
but i think it's more i mean that's just
saying
and the thing will somehow find its own
energy configuration but my claim would
be as soon as the computation gets hard
it will just not find them in our energy
configuration let me give an example
yeah we'll get stuck we'll get stuck
right so so i mean an example of this
uh okay analogous example
um
is uh freezing
of um
you know freezing of complicated
molecules
right where you can say you know
that freezing is you've got to arrange
them you know arrange all these
complicated molecules into a crystal
and i don't know what i i seem to
remember that if you look at just
uh you know big long hydrocarbons
that you eventually get this kind of you
know as you try to freeze them they
eventually just become mushy
because they don't definitively form a
crystal so is that true statement does
anybody know pretty much it would be
very hard to get them to be elongated uh
where they could pack nicely
into a crystal um
so that's a statement of basically
computational difficulty is there what's
the name
phenomenon in chemistry
what they don't crystallize yeah
uh
it's amorphous right it's an amorphous
state yeah that's right yeah okay thanks
jason
um
but now if i were to ask the question if
i have
a um
um you know let's say i remember i
looked at this in the nks book i just
had some picture
of
um
if i can find it
um
um
oh come now i thought i had some yeah
here we go
this was my my picture of um
the uh
uh
melting points
of molecules of different shapes
so my question would be if i get to the
point where
um
[Music]
you know is there some moment where i
can no longer put a put a definitive
point here
and how is that moment characterized
if that makes sense i mean if i look up
the
melting point i mean if i look at let's
just do it if i say
something like
okay chemistry help please give me give
me a class of things for which their
isomers that are
the hydrocarbons yeah okay what's what
do i do i say molecule of how do i get
the isomers
of
is there an entity class for that jason
or do we use chemical data to get those
let's see uh do you want to get all the
molecules with a particular formula
yeah let's say
the hydrocarbons for example all these
alkane things with just
so entity list of entity class chemical
alkanes
should uh have a decent no but i want
the ones for like say size eight
ah so like c8h16
yes i guess so yeah all of those right
so
the entity class chemical
and then um
it can either be a rule or a list of
rules i think so you then you do um
entity
let me look it up i believe you you have
to do entity property of chemical hill
formula
goes to and then a string
um
c
c eight h okay chemical
comma hill
i formula a nested program a while back
that would generate all of the hyzer
carpets of a given size
right
okay hold on let's so what do i want to
do here i want to say c
c8h16
right so that would have a one degree of
unsaturation if you want to fully uh
saturate it would be eight uh h18 oh
yeah these pic these ones and then you
have to do entity list on it
so that would be no
because the things i've drawn here yeah
i believe those are saturated those i
think yeah you might remember from the
nks book goes through the saturated
hydrocarbons
okay um
okay but joseph is saying that he
actually has something which which just
computes it graph theoretically i think
it's actually fairly easy to convert the
nest graph function into a traditional
nest function
but we can we can generate i mean these
graphs
what aspect to these okay
we can generate these graphs the thing i
was hoping to do is just look up what we
say the melting points of all these
things are and do they all have melting
points what will we say
if the thing becomes amorphous what do
we say for the melting point
either
be missing
not applicable
or not available most likely would be
not available yeah i guess it depends on
who put it in and when
yeah but but some amorphous things do
actually melt but
and they would be characterized by a
melting point
which is a
okay naive question about thermodynamics
so to speak
right the thermodynamic limit
okay
do amorphous materials have definitive
melting points
or are they a range of melting points
it could be
some of them i do melt but they melt
over a range
some of them may not melt at all and
decompose
right but okay but of the ones that i
mean the thermodynamic limit the theory
of phase transition says
if you have a phase transition there
will be a precise value of temperature
at which you get this sort of uh you
know change of phase but for an
amorphous material perhaps that is not
the case
yeah
okay
so
um
but i i guess my question here is
you know okay so what we're trying to
think about is
if we are trying to do computation with
molecules
sort of plan a
would be
like for example in this exercise of can
we generate alkanes let's say
with prime number
you know of prime number sizes is that
completely crazy is there any process we
can imagine that would do that
alkanes are uh particularly difficult
you definitely need a lot of computation
on top of that i just don't see what
computation uh would be available to
do that but
i
that doesn't necessarily rule out the
possibility well but i mean okay pick
something else i mean i i'd be happy to
have
any kind of um
like
polymer you know let's say okay let me
pick a different example okay let's just
use this
um i'd
just do here
um
so it was a little formula string and
that's why it didn't match earlier
ah
okay so that gives us that's kind of
cool actually
wow
that's so how do i get um how would i
get the actual molecules to go with
these so you could do um uh
nc association as the third third
argument to entity value there
and then keymap molecule
why is this taking so long
crumble grumble grumble right right
formatting them takes a little bit too
okay so that should be a version of this
picture up here
so all of these so then
i don't know that i mean i know the
wiener index
things for boiling points i don't think
there's an analogous i think this is a
much harder problem melting points
um
okay just for fun i mean we could do can
we
well
okay so this gives us a sense of this
but if we ask the question
um
what
uh
okay consider a polymer of some kind
is there any way we can imagine
saying i want a prime number of
polymeric units
i mean in a sense
okay the the question is what is the
right raw material for doing something
like what we've done here with the
cellular automaton so what we've done
here just to be clear
these are basically things that bounce
back and forth and they bounce back and
forth between barriers that are
progressively larger in size
thereby
basically killing off
and
anytime they bounce they're basically
making all multiples
as soon as
as soon as
there is a multiple to be made of
something it will make a stripe on the
side so the the gap stripes are the ones
where there is no multiple of anything
that makes that number
hence the prime
yep
okay
so i mean just as an example that would
be a case
you know could we imagine
so like if we can't do that
with the actual products
can we do that with the reaction network
that's the question for
for um
um
so for example to give an example
um
you know something i looked at
fairly recently
was if i can find it
um
here we go
multi-way turing machines okay so this
is
turing machines where the comp and i
don't really know where the computation
there are many parts right so this is an
ordinary turing machine just doing its
thing it has a definite evolution this
is a multi-way turing machine that can
have multiple branches of its evolution
right so the actual deterministic turing
machine goes down one particular branch
okay so the question is this is kind of
like our reaction network
if that makes sense
these are multiple branches that it can
go down and these things here are states
that could be thought of as as
particular molecules so then the
question is
you know in this setup where we have
this multi-way turing machine
is there a way in which the result of
the computation can be encoded
in the structure of this multi-way graph
you know this is basically
um
you know
the question is
can there be
a computation
encoded in the chemical network
basically
and we would use the
network
as the framework for a computation
[Music]
uh i think the point here is that we
would be using
um
the the network as
um
we'd be saying
the answer is this because the network
has the structure in the middle
see what i'm saying so in other words
we're not saying the answer is a
particular one of these that is my
favorite shaped molecule
we're saying somehow
and this is the question of whether this
is used in molecular biology or not
whether the actual time history of the
network could be something that is
relevant like like for instance
if you have some cycle
in um
you know again
well i don't i just don't know i mean
this is the okay my little thing from my
post from yesterday was the the
speculation that you know the big
innovation when people realized that dna
molecules could store information was a
single molecule can store information
that was not obvious before dna before
1953
but the question is can relevant
information be stored in the time
history of molecular interactions
and can that information somehow be
accessed by virtue of the fact that when
you are in some state
here with some particular time history
of molecules it's like the the lie to
the molecular chaos assumption of the
boltzmann equation of of well these
molecules aren't actually in completely
random states they have certain
orientations and momenta and so on and
which can be you know which matter and
which are determined by the structure of
this thing here
is that crazy
uh i won't comment on crazy but what i'm
thinking of here is the closest analogy
that i can think of is something like uh
these clock networks um
that that uh basically give you your you
know your internal clock for your
circadian rhythm it's not just the sun
rising and setting yeah right but
there's some chemical reactions that
take 24 hours and that's why you know
animals living entirely in the dark yeah
right still have these rhythms
but now aren't those just slow chemical
reactions
they are slow but
the
there's the feedback in there that lets
their concentrations rise and fall
periodically
right i haven't looked into them
but that's basically what they do i can
provide an example of a cyclical uh
reaction
yeah i mean right there are many i mean
i don't know what the the fastest one is
a fast one that's often done in a lab as
a toy experiment
uh the the uh bullish of zabatsuki e
reaction i i can't pronounce it probably
easy
reaction yeah yeah right yes i mean
those tend to have so what's interesting
about the bz reaction
is that it has you know it has a spatial
dependence to it tends to have reaction
diffusion type stuff
but that's which is which is relevant i
mean that's used in biology plenty
that's used in all kinds of pigmentation
pattern type things and so on and that
again has spatial dependence i guess
okay
okay um
but these they're you know they're there
are several oscillator circuits and they
they are
been they've been fairly extensively
studied
right so this is okay so this is the
thing where one is using bz reactions on
a plate
great yeah that's fine that's that's
nice yeah
the
right
well it's like cellular automata
exactly like cellular automata
i've just modeled that as differential
equations and you can see the
concentrations you know rising and
falling periodically and
when a certain you know when one of the
components exceeds a certain amount the
color changes to orange and then you
know it goes
clear
right when it falls below that
um
let's see but i'm i'm still pushing
on
uh
and i need to go in a second here but
but um
um
i don't know
i'm just wondering if the prime problem
is is too hard to do chemically if
there's something else
that we could compute with um
the uh
in your combinator paper there there was
uh you had an example of you know
enumerating the integers
and uh you know you could certainly do
that yeah by just you know making you
know a longer longer longer polymer
um with your process to do right but see
but the thing is what i really want to
the whole point is we need a framework
we need primitives
like combinators for example
where
by
you know what what is the mechanism by
which we think this could work basically
what has to happen is
that some external stimulus
i mean okay so how do you program
how do you program the molecules how do
you program the chemical system
so one thing is
uh you know put in certain initial
conditions
that's thing number one thing number two
is
you know flash light at it or something
that's what else could you do
you could put magnetic fields
you can heat it
yeah definitely temperature heating
cooling uh you can change the ph
yes yeah that's true which is but now ph
is
that's a little bit trickier because ph
is is like adding another compound to
the thing so another so i think another
another category is
change ph
versus
slash add some other
you know wash it with some other wash
through with you know
wash in some other
uh compound yeah
and
it sounds like you're you're thinking of
more like a bulk reactor you know it's
essentially a test tube and another
aspect that could be considered
is
a flow system where you have it flowing
through a long thin tube
and things can be done at different
points along the tube i see
um
[Music]
this is a kind of chemistry that
came about after i was out of the lab so
i'm not that familiar with it
but but you see but the point about it
is what i'm imagining is
that yes you do that i mean basically
what's going to happen is there's a big
multi-way graph of all these reactions
that are happening and you are changing
the multi-way graph in some way you're
determining you've got a basic
you know structure that's that's that's
happening here you know in a sense
okay thinking it physics like
you've got the underlying sort of thing
that's knitting together the structure
of space
and then these things that you're doing
to it like flashing light at it or
whatever else or washing it through with
some acid or something um those are
things that are like
uh sort of things happening in space and
they cause a perturbation and the
multi-way graph
and what you're looking at then
is the kind of
on that
on that substrate of the underlying you
know quote structure of space from the
multi-way graph you're asking
what
effects
you know
what you might think
okay so you're asking
is there some sort of yes this what what
is the um
uh in a sense it's like um
given
given a background
multi-way structure
you know
what is the effective physics
of making certain perturbations
if you see what i'm saying so in other
words the idea would be the computation
happens by virtue of these perturbations
so computation
is through
certain persistence perhaps is through
certain persistent perturbations i don't
know that's like particles for example
uh
um
oh wow there's a
richard is commenting cicadas make
primes that's a good point
um oh in terms of their reproductive
cycle yes that's true
although does anybody know how
i do not
i think that may be an unknown thing how
that works
i think it's i think the belief is that
it's slow chemical reactions of various
kinds
probably an oscillator again some kind
of clock that controls uh the pupation
yeah right
like a circadian rhythm but it happens
to be seven years long
yes
right
um
yeah i know i i like that example
cicadas
cicadas and circadians cicadas are
circadian that's confusing
um
the uh
um
and uh
let's see
there's a comment here i think this may
be by chap i know
this about a paper
biological generator oh well
um
that's cool oh yeah i know eric gollus
um
cool okay how does this work
oh it's about cicadas
what do you know let's see what they say
um and then i need to go to a different
meeting but but um
eric golis was just joined us for the um
discussion we did of distributed
consensus which by the way is not
completely irrelevant to um
to this question okay so
okay predator fitness it's got a gcd hey
wait a minute i'm not a believer in that
there ain't no gcds
the the organisms that create gcds are
few and far between in my opinion
um but that's interesting i mean in uh
uh okay i think we have to look at this
in more detail
um
but the thing about the cicadas is that
uh
they only generate if you want to use
the term generate a few primes
i know
but
look in i mean these things look there
are physical processes like ones in the
cochlea that you know
have you know we get certain musical
things are pleasing because of certain
you know interference
fringes effectively but that's again
that's that doesn't sort of doesn't
count i mean i think
um i mean the thing that i'm interested
in is
you know is there a way to have i think
that the the right way to think about
this is probably that there's an
underlying multi-way graph of some
complicated set of chemical reactions
and
that we have certain perturbations we
can make on those chemical reactions
and that the working out of those
perturbations
corresponds to a computation
would that be restricting to a
particular path through the multi way no
no the whole idea would be the graph
would change
perturbation right you make a
perturbation and the whole difference
between the way you think about it
normally with chemicals is
the effect of the perturbation actually
i had never really thought about this is
perturbations in multi-way graphs i mean
that's a good um
uh
um
you know so actually i think i did think
about it i think there's something in it
about it in the um
in the physics um
project uh technical background document
that i wrote
um
um but that's that will be the thing
that the perturbation in the multi-way
graph you know in other words the the
underlying structure of all these
reactions and so on in a sense is like
the knitting together of space in
physics
and then the perturbations are where the
kind of interesting action is
um and that's um
um
the uh
um
yeah i actually like that idea and i
think that's what we see you know in a
random cellular automaton for example
you know we're seeing computation happen
by virtue of certain
for example topologically stable objects
interacting so the question is
is there
are there
um topologically stable structures in
multi-way graphs
and i bet the answer is yes
um and by the way uh just to not be too
exotic but i suspect that's related to
bizarre phenomena in multi-multi-body
quantum mechanics
because in a sense what's happening is
you know quantum mechanics is a story of
the branchial structure of this sort of
the the
entanglement
of things on a particular slice of one
of these graphs
and so by saying that there is a
topologically stable structure once
saying that in bronchial space there's a
topologically stable structure which is
actually something i've not thought
about properly
that's the possibility of essentially
particles in branchial space
um the uh
i mean they're particles in physical
space but what do particles look like in
bronchial space
in other words what um
uh boy that's an interesting idea
okay um
uh
okay richard is commenting the
hypography write rule that results in a
continuous dynamical system whose
solution is the two most constant
yes i mean i found a bunch of hypograph
rewrite rules where the count of the
number of states generated is a
fibonacci number or something like this
by the way fibonacci is definitely
easier than primes i just decided to
pick something hard
um the um all right we have to wrap up
unfortunately but someone was commenting
that um are we watching the invention of
the chemical computer in real time well
maybe
the um
these chemical computers are trying to
create
uh
there's definitely something to find
here i mean this is there's
there's a kind of a i think there's a
way of thinking about
sort of
computation in chemical space which is
effectively what this is as opposed to
computation in
in
well it isn't really even in chemical
space it's in it's in chemical history
space
as opposed to just in concentration
space
anyway i need to go um but uh
thanks for coming guys and um
uh thanks for joining us on the live
stream some good suggestions much
appreciated and uh we will continue
another time
all right
bye for now